[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis we are here for between two ponds
and the first time I get to host my name
is Ben Simon and I'm here with my
special guest today Grandmaster and
residents Amon Hamilton come on welcome
to the house
thanks very much Ben I can't be here so
you are one of the chess brahs the
famous chess brahs how did the chess
bra's come to be it's a good question
probably the question I think that I get
asked the most you know Eric and I met
as kids we would competed against each
other but you know it's not like we had
chess bra aspirations since I was a
young one it's not what you say when
you're in class and they say what do you
want to be when you grow up and I said a
chess bro it wouldn't really make sense
no not quite like that yeah so it was a
little bit later we were both sort on
the same trajectory similar age both
found ourselves in university at the
same time both ended up dropping out of
university and traveling to Europe to do
chess like full-time and it was right
then when Eric started streaming in a
basement in the Netherlands and that's
basically the first first time that we
streamed on the channel and we just been
in streaming and playing blitz online
ever since now how does one become a
chess bra well there's the obvious
hazing procedure you know there's just
the rituals the the drawing of blood I
mean there's all these standard
practices but now really really we do
have quite an extensive team of people
that either work for us like employees
contractors or people that are good
friends of ours and appear on stream
from time to time like Fabiano comes on
stream definitely consider him him and
Schatz brought a knee played for our
protest League team recently so we
definitely have like a large number of
people that you could consider
Jesper oz but there's no sort of special
procedure or not but I would say
appearing on stream semi-regularly is
probably probably very important to to
that before the recent spring chess
classic I asked you if you had any kind
of signature things that you do and you
said well not really
I like imitations and that's what you've
done on your channel many times a lot of
different people I don't think you've
done me but I definitely know that Mike
comer has been done many times so how
did the imitation things start
well I've it's always been interesting
for me I think like when I was younger I
would recite movie scripts because that
a lot of times my family or my parents
found it funnier when I told the joke
that was in a movie versus when they
heard it in the movie the first time so
I would like retell jokes that I thought
were funny I remember that part in that
movie when the guy said it and I would
retell the joke and I would often even
sound a little bit different or maybe
better than they were the original so it
started with like movie scripts and just
memorizing those TV shows stuff I found
funny I would always just retell it and
I think I was always a bit of a joker
when it came to my friends like I'm
always sort of picking on somebody or or
trying to find the funny in the
situation so it's just natural to me to
take a spin on anything and make it
funny do you have a feud with Mike comer
I I know that
so I maybe did an impression of him
first and then I think Mike made a video
for like a tournament once where I mean
I'll be generous and call it an
impression of me that he did in the
video and I mean I haven't really sort
of retaliated by since done you know a
Mike Hammer impression on stream before
yeah after that so it was kind of in an
impersonation of you doing an
impersonation of him
Zac and it had be generated to the point
where no one really knew what he was
saying anymore well that's the thing is
that I always say it's very hard for
people to impersonate me because I'm
often never speaking as myself I'm often
doing impersonations of other people so
it's very hard - how does it Mons I'm
like well sometimes he sounds like Mike
come here sometimes it sounds like
Macklemore I mean who knows so the man
of many faces you're the Pokemon dito of
the chess world exactly yeah so Aman you
come from Toronto right yeah how is the
chess scene girl you grew up in Toronto
yeah I wasn't
born there but I consider that what
considered my hometown has spent the
most time there especially those those
key years where you make those memories
so I was born on the east coast of
Canada in Nova Scotia and but I spent
the longest time in in Toronto how did
you the chess scenes compared to the
chess scenes in the US yeah it's a good
question even within Canada you'll have
chess scenes that are like incomparable
to one another so the chassis and on the
east coast of Canada where I initially
grew up was I mean very poor or
non-existent I mean they did the best
with what they had I actually really
enjoyed myself there so I was quite
young and that actually got me into
chess quite seriously but in terms of
competition you go to Toronto is way
different and then you leave Canada and
it's way different so there's like
different levels first it starts off in
Eastern Canada and maybe you have
Toronto bigger cities Calgary has a nice
chest area now as well Montreal we spent
a lot of time living there Eric and I
and I think we definitely contributed to
to making that scene grow a little bit
but when you step into this the States
or Europe for example Europe and there's
just chess culture and it makes a huge
difference there's there's support for
chess and it's not it's not like a big
deal if there was and Canada landing at
chess sponsors like unheard of for I
think like national TV or something but
Europe there's culture for it in America
there's there's backing there's
tournaments all the time and it's just
people want to play there's that chess
bug so quite simply people want to play
and there's chess clubs that are you
know bursting at the seams with
participants because there's just so
many eager people that they want to get
involved right yeah it's like st. Louis
there wasn't really a chess culture we
had people playing but we kind of
artificially created this chess
experience that now is turning into a
culture it's a rare thing that the
Western Hemisphere doesn't seem to have
a lot of so you've taught a lot of
classes here in your time as the game
master in res which is your favorite to
teach well so so far I've done a few
different types so there's the let's say
the kids classes there's a few of them
but let's just say kids classes in
general there's a puzzle class we're
basically just show a bunch of tactics
you know from easy to very difficult
there's the chess in the Romantic era
class and there's my greatest losses so
probably of all these classes which one
is my favorite would probably be the
puzzle class because you just sit there
and you put a puzzle on the screen and
you say solve it so that's a great class
I mean that's fantastic but which one
did I maybe enjoy the most I happened to
enjoy researching some of my awful chess
games you know it's always very
enjoyable to go over your loss has been
so I really it really took that to heart
and I really look at some games that I
never looked at in like such a long time
so that was kind of that was kind of
funny but you know that was my idea that
well class the whole class I told the
club for three years we got to do my
greatest losses and they brushed me off
each time and now now we're doing it
yeah yeah that's it it's a good class it
made me made me go back in the databases
you know those those good losses are
hard to find
so I thought oh that was uh that was fun
you hosted the spring chess classic a
couple weeks ago along with me what did
you take away from that tournament well
Ben I mean you just have a really
glowing personality and I think it
definitely rubbed off in the best way so
really I just I just take that to heart
and I'm just going to look to improve my
commentary to to match up to the
standard that you set here the st. Louis
Chess Club know spectacular you had a
gold set for you a couple of years ago
man I think it's been that long ago
where you were an international master
and you were looking for your final
Grandmaster norm and you setup it I'm
not shaving my face until I get that
Norman you had quite a mighty beard tell
us about this adventure of yours and I
mean here we are today and I'm just so
clean-shaven
no one could ever expect that I'm
capable of that
you know the baby-faced but I did I sort
of I was taking a trip Eric actually
joined me I went to Sweden and played a
chess tournament there and it went so
poorly like it started off I lost my
first game to like just a 1900 or
something and I was I was obviously
really upset and I said as soon as I
lost the game I went back to the hotel
room Eric was there and I said like okay
well I'm just gonna first of all I said
I'm gonna make my GM title by the end of
2017
so that was one goal which was actually
separate from the beard and then the
other thing I said was that I was going
to grow my beard until I became a
grandmaster some sort of ultimate
punishment that if I couldn't do it in
2017 then I'm just gonna look like an
even crazier person than than usual okay
you ever doubt it though I mean what if
you just never got the norm this has
happened before I mean you're just gonna
have the beard for the rest of your life
huh basically yeah and and the thing is
I made sort of some fun bats with my
stream or the people that follow and
support sort of chests bra or maybe just
me and I've made some fun bets before on
stream I've shaved my my head before on
stream I've you know colored my my my
hair before not that this was a bet or a
dare or anything like that but I I'm
willing to you know stand by my word so
when I say that I'm gonna grow my beard
out I mean it was very uncomfortable
even just having it for that one year I
mean you can't eat or drink properly
when the beard is in your mouth so I
mean even that was uncomfortable a lot
of people probably wouldn't do that
maybe a lot of people wouldn't shave
their head but I'm willing to take these
these I mean they're not even risks just
sort of fun adventures because I think
it brought a lot of attention to me
going for the GM title there's a lot of
fun for people to follow along and sort
of like it's fun either way he looks
like in like a complete idiot or he
makes a GM title and either way I think
the people sort of enjoyed that but I
was obviously very very happy to have
actually reached both my goals which was
before the end of 2017 and finally get
to shave off that beard which I did on
an ice chest broth stream on New Year's
so that was a lot of fun I was right
before Christmas right before my
birthday and before New Year's so I was
like one of the perfect ends probably
like the greatest like end to a year
that I've ever had I'll give you a
choice with this next one because it's
really basic and pretty broad all right
tell us about either your favorite
tournament experience or your favorite
over the board rated game you've played
favorite tournament experience or
favorite tournament game or just rated
game
you ready game yeah okay it's probably
easier for me to remember a tournament
because there's less of those there's a
lot of I played a lot of rated games and
favorite I mean oh now now I actually
remember maybe some some games
I've had some I've had some sort of like
things happen in some of my games that I
guess I wouldn't expect to have happened
to many other people a few of them like
I laid a play to tournament in Italy and
this was when I was an international
master and basically what I did was I
played a game against an Indian
Grandmaster at the time and he
completely outplayed me like he he just
he had me killed the whole game and it
came down not even to a time scramble
but just a position where my King had
actually taken a stroll out into the
board and he was one of those positions
that you almost just resigned but you
sort of say okay I'll let him play one
more move just to show me that he knows
and he played a move and he put out his
hand when he made the move and it was so
weird because I was like a case was he
offering me a draw and I realized that
he was announcing that it was checkmate
so he was saying like good game he was
like pausing the clock almost but the
move that he made hung his entire Queen
and so I just took it in many resign
and this was a grand mass that's tragic
I've just I've never like I didn't
realize that that could actually happen
to me and when it did it was so surreal
yeah I didn't realize grandmasters could
hang full pieces not on the internet
people do that I do that all the time
but in a tournament game on a dgt board
just made a move and sort of like you
know almost got up like it's just it's
over why it's checkmate I almost said it
out loud
check me you know I haven't done that
since I was a kid but it actually hung
his entire Queen and I just took it I
mean I felt of course bad but not that
bad it was that in the distant past how
long ago did that happen
that was maybe to 2014 I want to say
around 2014 yeah so is it safe to say at
this point you're a professional chess
player yes I guess or personality yeah
the word player is is I guess thrown
around a lot I would say that that
definitely you know probably gonna use
that term because I don't know how else
to really define it especially if I'm
talking to someone else is that's the
best way to describe me but lately I've
been doing less and less playing I still
want to keep it up and I still hope to
play big tournaments like maybe the
national championship to try to qualify
for the World Cup where we have a spot
or our national team for the Olympiad
and such and otherwise try to compete in
some big international tournaments when
I have the time but I'm doing a lot to
do with chess that's not playing so
that's why it feels slightly
disingenuous to just say I'm a
professional chess player because there
are professional chess players out there
and I don't play as much as them I don't
study as much as them so you know I do a
lot of commentating do a lot of
streaming and like you said it's sort of
being more like a personality and just
trying to grow the brand of chess bra
and you know sort of be an ambassador
for that and for chess do you teach any
private lessons of so like how can
people get involved yeah I used to teach
a lot more probably the same with
playings like I used to teach way more
but I've just got so much busy with with
everything else that I don't teach that
much anymore so it was something that
I guess a lot of chess players do to
actually finance their chess playing is
that you teach lessons you have the
money to travel to your own tournaments
that I was doing that when I was
traveling around the world basically and
I've since stopped that so I've
basically wanted to rededicate myself to
the stream which I took a lot of time
off from and Eric was able to manage
mainly while I was trying to get the GM
title and so since then it's been all
you know everything that I do just goes
back into the stream the channel and the
YouTube but just everything to do with
with the brands so I'm not I'm not
teaching that that many private classes
anymore
and on Twitch it's chess bras right
that's the name of the channel
it's just bra yeah chest bra chest bra
twitch.tv slash chest bra cool yeah
should definitely check that out
I'm on everybody has goals in life and
whenever you're a little kid if you're
ambitious you might want to be the world
champion or you might want to get your
first title but you're a grandmaster now
what is your next goal in life yeah I
mean becoming Grandmaster wasn't let's
say lifelong goal but is definitely a
recent goal like let's say since I
became I am and I had all the momentum I
didn't want to get stuck in that place
that a lot of players in Canadian chess
gets stuck in specifically Canada where
we don't have a lot of norm tournaments
or opportunities you have to travel it's
not many players that I've ever became a
grandmaster inside of Canada so you have
to travel and I didn't want to get stuck
in that territory rate before GM so it
was a big goal in mind to actually
become a grandmaster now that I've done
that I mean I have goals to do with the
channel like I want I really want chess
brought it'd be like one of the biggest
things ever I'm proud of like how it's
taken off already but I want that to
keep growing more than anything for my
own chess I would like to be you know
definitely a solid like mid-20 500
Grandmaster I don't really have it might
happen but I don't have aspirations to
put in effort to become a twenty six
twenty seven hundred I just want to be
you know let's say if I was mid twenty
five hundred I probably be one of the
better players in Canada I mean
that would really put me in like the top
top three let's say so something like
that is a is a minor chess cool of mine
but otherwise most of my goals have to
do with you know get getting involved in
in things online like growing the
channel again involved in eSports and
all these other things that that
interest me that are not necessarily
chess related but I want to see chess
bra grow and I want chess to become more
popular more interesting for people and
sort of change the stigma that that it
has so that's like a that's a lifelong
goal yes you mentioned other eSports and
we know that chess is fast becoming the
East Board if it's not there already
what other eSports are you involved in
yeah no first of all chess is definitely
making waves on Twitch and you know
obviously we're a part of that but we're
by no means the only driving factor we
got a lot of people starting to stream
now and that's become pretty regular
thing chess comm is putting on some
pretty serious twitch events and mean
tournaments are starting a broadcast I
think I saw feed a was broadcasting on
Twitch really the the World Team
Championship on like a feed a twitch and
it's the first time I'd ever seen that
so I was like pretty impressed pretty
impressed there it's good to see so
chess is doing well but otherwise I mean
I like a lot of other eSports like
League of Legends pub G csgo
and I'm just we try to always try to
model our success off the success of
other big popular eSports how can we
sell the game of chess how can we sell
our stream sell ourselves to you know
these bigger sponsors bigger companies
and we want to get them involved in
supporting us supporting chess so we
like to model them off some of the big
high production broadcasts that other
eSports put on regularly very cool
so Aman you're about to leave st. Louis
your residency is almost up
unfortunately yeah what's next for you
yeah well big plans with with the
channel just regular streaming and
YouTube stuff all year and that that's
actually you know kind of
daily thing for me so it's not nothing
new and it's it's definitely enjoyable
but I'm playing Reykjavik the Reykjavik
open that's in April
there's also twitchcon Europe I think
Eric see me going there that'll be fun
that's also in April and after that I
mean who knows but we we have a lot of
plans that involve traveling or meetups
or big events that we want to actually
put on and you know I can't really let's
say you know reveal exactly what they
all are but we we have plans that go a
lot further than just turning on our
stream so we want to use the the
following that our stream has and you
know do some really cool in-person
events or whatever we think that that's
that's where you know the action is if
we can put anything like that together
that's that's always the the biggest
goal so how can the fans follow you on
social media yeah well I have I have a
Twitter and an Instagram both of those
are just Adam on Hambleton pretty easy
just my full name and we have a we have
a chest bra Twitter as well of course we
have the twitch channel chest bra and we
have a youtube channel as well so we're
actually just everywhere all the social
medias we usually have a chest bra page
as well as I just have my own my own
pages there to reach me well aman it's
been a pleasure thank you for joining me
here at the house for between two ponds
and thank you for watching here on the
world's greatest chess youtube channel
st. Louis chess club my humble opinion
until next time Grandmaster I'm on
Hamilton thank you very much my name is
Ben Simon we'll see you at the Chess
Club
[Music]
you